You can just tell from watching Donald Trump's
rallies this week that there's something new
going on.
There is a sort of desperate anger, I would
call it, that wasn't really there before.
And it culminated in humiliating fashion last
night with Donald Trump at a rally in Erie,
Pennsylvania, which started nearly 50 minutes
late for no particular reason.
I covered part of it live.
Donald Trump telling the audience he doesn't
even want to be there, but he's losing now
and he sort of has to be there.
He doesn't want to, but he had to do it.
Great way to get the audience on your side.
Right.
Take a look.
Because, you know, before the plague came
in, I had it made.
I wasn't coming to Erie.
I mean, I have to be honest, there's no way
I was coming.
I didn't have to.
I would've called today.
You know, if you have a chance.
Get out.
But we had this thing one.
We were so far up.
We had the greatest economy ever.
Greatest jobs, greatest everything.
And then we got hit with the plague.
And I had to go back to work.
Hello, Weary.
I wouldn't be here if I didn't have to because
I screwed up the Corona virus response.
Imagine if Barack Obama had ever said that.
Imagine if Joe Biden said that during this
election or if Hillary Clinton had said that
back in 2016.
I really don't want to be here, but I had
to come here to this lame place because I'm
losing.
And by the way, if you don't vote for me,
I will never come back.
Which Donald Trump has been saying in Pennsylvania
and in North Carolina and in many other places.
And by the way, this idea that Corona virus
had to hurt him, that inevitably the virus
hurt him.
So now he has to campaign.
World leaders who did a good job with the
virus are cruising to reelection.
Jacinda Ardern in New Zealand sailed to overwhelming
reelections and a bigger Labor majority than
I think New Zealand has ever seen because
she handled the Corona virus properly.
As I've said before, if Trump had handled
the virus properly, Biden would have no shot
right now.
So that's also completely wrong.
Then maybe the most humiliating moment of
this rally.
Donald Trump saying nobody wants him.
Really?
I can't believe it.
You'd better give me the credit.
Damn it, I'll take what I've put what I've
gone through.
The drug companies are spending a fortune
on fake ads.
They don't want me.
China doesn't want me.
Iran doesn't want.
Nobody wants.
Airy area one, it's easy to write this stuff
off as merely the rantings of a madman.
But I think there is something real here,
which is Donald Trump does see the polls and
even though publicly he says he's winning,
he knows he might lose.
He does realize that everything he's doing
is sinking him further and further.
He does the first debate.
The polls collapse.
He continues to crater in many important states.
And I think Trump is cognizant of that.
And that's why you're seeing this attitude
for four from Donald Trump.
Trump then still confused about how stealth
planes work.
Trump still seems to think that stealth planes
are invisible to the naked eye rather than
invisible to enemy radar.
We now have the greatest equipment we've ever
had.
We are the envy of Russia and China and everybody
in the world.
We have the best missiles and rockets and
tanks and planes.
F-35 stealth.
You can't see it other than that.
It's not so great.
You can't see it.
I went to one of the pilots.
I said, how good is his?
Well, it's really good.
Why is it good?
Because the enemy can't see it.
Is it?
I don't know too much about what you do.
Sounds good to me.
Continuing that old trope.
And then a bizarre moment when Republican
Congressman Mike Kelly says no flu is going
to keep Trump down again, rehabilitating this
false notion that Corona is the flu.
This is the time.
This is your solemn oath to America.
We're going to make America great again.
Again because of Donald J. Trump.
There is no flu, there's gonna keep this man
down.
He makes the Energizer Bunny look like a dead
head, no flu.
Keeping Trump down.
But nine hundred fifty two Americans did die
yesterday as we approach Spike.
Number three of Corona virus.
Here is a completely incoherent thought from
Donald Trump.
I can't even pretend to explain this one to
you.
It's a verbal inkblot.
Take a look.
You seen what's been going on?
How well we're doing.
Did you see the recent poll just came out.
Fifty six percent of the people want to be
here.
Not four years ago.
They want to be with us in what we're calling.
We're rounding the turn on the pandemic.
Fifty six percent.
And it's a record epic job growth.
Safe vaccines that quickly end the pandemic.
It's the normal life.
That's all we want.
You know, we want normal life.
Just not making any sense.
And then Trump, I guess, wrapping up sort
of early yesterday because it was cold in
Erie, Pennsylvania.
Trump sounding sedated by the end.
Listen to the slow motion version of Trump's
now ubiquitous rally closing that I know you
well a lot of time in this incredible land,
this beautiful place, his place of history,
the incredible people of Pennsylvania.
We have made America powerful again.
Our military never been like this.
Remember at the beginning when the overrated
generals said to me, Sir, we have no ammunition.
I said, no president should ever have that.
No president should ever hear those words.
Sir, we have no ammunition.
We now have so much ammunition that even Mike
would be impressed.
Wrapping up there with a sort of sedated sounding
nod to the military industrial complex Trump
tonight in Charlotte, North Carolina.
And then, of course, tomorrow night, the second
and what will be the final presidential debate
between Joe Biden and Donald Trump?
I will be covering it live on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook.
I hope you will join me at about half past
8:00 p.m. Eastern Time.
And, of course, continued coverage clips,
polling, Meems, and other hijinx on The David
Pakman Show Instagram at David Pakman show
again, if you want to see me voting very strongly.
Voting over the weekend.
Catch video of me voting on my Instagram page.
David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break.
Our deep dove into systemic racism.
Coming up after the break